[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Buckingham Palace on the eve of the
coronation of King Charles III
camping overnight for a view of the king
and rewarded with a handshake thousands
line them all
my mum and dad went to the queens and my
dad talked about nothing for about it
and talked about it all the time before
he died so yeah it's really special it's
my seventh event here
before his crowning a reception for
world leaders at Buckingham Palace
[Music]
outside tight security with protests
expected and a warning officers will
move to stop any disruption
exclusive polling for Sky News suggests
the king is more popular just than the
royal family but support for a republic
is rising
but up and down the country young and
old prepare to celebrate the coronation
of the new king
[Music]
hello good evening welcome to a Sky News
special program live from Buckingham
Palace tomorrow a king is crowned the
eyes of the world will be on the longest
serving air apparent as he is formally
bestowed with Regal powers in a
religious ceremony at Westminster Abbey
we'll bring you the details of what key
moments to look out for and we'll be
speaking to someone playing a prominent
role in the coronation service
well tomorrow an occasion for pageantry
and celebration and also a solemn
religious ceremony today though a more
relaxed atmosphere as the king and the
prince and princess of Wales greeted
crowds of well-wishers on them all many
of whom had camped out overnight a royal
correspondent Laura bundock reports
they'd come to see him so when he went
to see them this was the reaction
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
how did he seem to you really friendly
yeah he seemed really nice nervous at
all do you think no he plays it cool
no I didn't think so
and for one Frenchman the British
royalty have really left a mark it's for
the safer Camilla
the safer of Elizabeth II and the safer
of the this of Elizabeth
on either side crowds lined The Mao and
Royals Walked the Line The Prince and
Princess of Wales taking time to chat
and thank the fans I'm going to be here
tonight
just over 2 000 people have invites a
guest list recast to reflect modern
society
how do you think you'll feel when you're
sat inside the Abbey I do think I will
be looking to wipe back at eye a tear or
or something like that because it is
something that's uh you know amazing
experience to be involved in with one
day to go one final rehearsal for the
king and queen consort complete with
robes and regalia
and then to greet their guests the pool
of a royal ceremony bringing together a
who's who of global politics what's been
exciting is to see leaders coming from
the four corners of the world to
celebrate this and for all of our 56
members of the Commonwealth representing
2.5 billion people
there are a lot of views about this
coronation the king and the monarchy but
take a step back and this remains a
hugely significant moment in British
history and one that very few will have
seen before
they've been waiting days for the
coronation but the Kings waited longer
than any other British monarch and his
time has almost come
well we'll bring in Laura shortly but
first let's take you through what to
expect tomorrow
at 7 30 in the morning guests will begin
arriving at Westminster Abbey
the king's procession will depart from
Buckingham Palace at 10 20. arriving
outside the Abbey's West door shortly
before the service begins at 11.
the king will be crowned around halfway
through the ceremony
then at one o'clock the new king and
queen will depart in a coronation
procession that will take around 45
minutes to return to Buckingham Palace
and finally at 2 30 they'll be joined by
members of the royal family on the
palace balcony members of the public on
the mall will then be treated to a
military fly past to round off the day
well Laura joins me now and Laura the
king uh busy today seems relaxed seems
ready hosting guests in in the palace
behind us that's right this is the third
event the king's been to today so this
is basically all the world's good and
great gathering at Buckingham Palace
there's nothing like a royal ceremony
like a coronation that will really bring
out the global leaders here so that's
underway at the moment but you're right
I'm told he's in good spirits very much
wanting to get out and about today he
had this last full dress rehearsal I'm
told it involved everything basically
ironing out the last few little bits
that perhaps needed some work on for for
the service but this is what the crowds
had wanted to see you mean the weather
has been pretty changeable today and I'm
told that's exactly what the king wanted
to do he wanted to see them and he
wanted to say thank you because don't
remember don't forget we've never had a
moment where the king knows these crowds
are all here just for him because that's
what this coronation is all about and
they are the Die Hard fans I mean some
of them camping for days and days but
talk to them and it really makes a
difference I met Bernadette from Canada
she was saying how in 1953 her parents
had come to London for the The Queen's
coronation and here she is 70 years on
and the fact we're getting these
walkabouts is another sort of modern
moment I think and I think one of the
big challenges has always been how you
harmonize in the 21st century this
really ancient ceremony and how you try
and make it feel a bit more modern and
relevant and we've seen the king doing
that with the guest list haven't we
we've seen it with the involvement of
other Faith leaders having these
ceremonial roles we'll have a Hindu
prime minister giving a Bible reading
but this sort of sense of innovation
um in terms of the ceremony and and how
that all plays out it's been interesting
because remember 1953 the very very
different Britain wasn't it I was trying
to remember how many guests from 53 will
be in the Abbey tomorrow I mean the King
was a little boy I imagine there's a
couple of others but you could probably
me count them on one hand most of us
have never seen a coronation before let
alone what's meant to be a more modern
version of that and really the hours are
ticking down before we find out exactly
what that's going to look like okay
Laura thanks very much it's going to be
a fascinating day
well our Royal events commentator
Alistair Bruce is joining me now plus
Christina curioski former communication
secretary to uh Prince Charles and The
Duchess of Cornwall but first let's take
a look at some of the key events of the
day
I'm Aleister Bruce and these are the key
moments to look out for in King Charles
III's coronation here at Westminster
Abbey
the first thing to look out for will be
the Excellence of the ceremonial
pageantry delivered by the Armed Forces
will bring the king in his Carriage here
to The Abbey and then return him in the
gold State coach back to Buckingham
Palace
inside the Abbey will be the glory of
the music
foreign
much of it has been specially
commissioned by the king for this
service but there will be traditional
music that takes us back to the whole
story of this coronation Through the
Ages
[Applause]
look out for the oath the king will make
three promises and then he will sign a
document and it's the only time a
monarch will sign a written Covenant
with his people
[Music]
perhaps the most poignant moment in the
ceremony will come when the King's son
the Prince of Wales will kneel before
him and make homage he will place his
hands together and dedicate his life to
serve his father
[Music]
part of the coronation ceremony will be
the anointing when the king is Anointed
with oil on his head on his chest and on
his hands
and this will be followed immediately by
the investiture of all the symbols of
sovereignty and the crowning itself
well our Royal events commentator Alice
Reese joins me now plus Christina
kiriaku former Communications secretary
to the then Prince Charles and The
Duchess of Cornwall lovely to see you
both
um Alice says you first of all are all
the preparations done is that are all
the t's crossed and the eyes dotted or
there will there be lots happening
tonight well I hope so they've been
rehearsing a great deal the King was in
The Abbey again today and it's really
important the Earl Marshall has put his
plan together the Archbishop of
Canterbury has prepared the service the
armed forces have supported the whole
project but all of them have been
rehearsing like mad and what we will see
tomorrow is what Britain does best we're
going to see the Armed Forces come out
and do their part to take the king to
The Abbey we'll see the finest of the
liturgical music that has been prepared
by unbelievable musicians not only with
music from the past but also modern
compositions have been put together for
the coronation at the King's request and
then I think there's just going to be a
panoply of music and we're going to see
signs and symbols that have resonance
right back to the start of time in this
nation and I think that even if you find
it really difficult to watch there is a
story there and I think it'll be
wonderful to see it all and if you can
just let the story permeate and be a
part of it because it belongs to us all
Christina you you know the king how much
do you think the ceremony itself means
to him well I know he has a very very
strong faith and his interactions with
all faiths
um in the past 30 years have have been
incredible he really does see himself as
protector of faiths and so that will be
an enormously uh huge part for him but I
think the celebration and I think also
emotion he'll be thinking of his mother
he was of course four years old when the
coronation happened last time and he was
watching so the last time he was in The
Abbey for a coronation was then and 70
years later here he is having had 60 of
those years working so hard to do good
to in public service very much
absolutely the monarching waiting and I
think he'll be reflecting on all of that
and
um what this means for the future as
well Alistair is there a particularly
tricky part of the day I mean there's
obviously the very key moment where he
when he is actually Crown King but it
but is there is there a part you think
that the military who are here and all
those who've organized it will just
breathe a small sigh of relief when it's
finished
the armed forces are really good at this
and they've been being trained under the
guidance of the major general command in
the household Division and the Garrison
sergeant major here in London district
and I can tell you there is nobody as
good as them to put these things
together I think it'll be fine and the
Armed Forces do that very well within
the church you have a ceremony that is
resonant with history and meaning and I
think whatever the king's preparations
it will be quite awe-inspiring for him
to take the Oaths that he will take
and to make a signature of of contract
with the people that he will rule well
according to the laws etc etc
but I think for him the pressure of
knowing so much attention is on every
detail of this ceremony I know that the
anointing of the king will be out of
sight but all the rest of it will be
very much inside and when that five
pound in weight crime is placed on his
head
you know that's that's quite a weight to
carry and I I sense with the golden
robes that have have connections right
back to Byzantium I mean these stories
are going to be I think fascinating to
see it played out in front of a modern
audience but for the king there's quite
a lot of pressure on him well as you say
you know philosophical as well as an
actual practical weight uh for him for
him to carry Christina it's incredible
to think that he wasn't really involved
in the succession planning uh for this
event because it obviously also meant
the death of his mother but do you think
he would have been very very closely
involved in it since that point I think
subsequently knowing his attention to
detail as I do he will have been
involved I can remember so many times in
the household he would never speak of a
supposed kingsmanship or or succession
planning because it did mean the death
of his Dear Mama but now knowing his
attention to detail knowing he you know
the sustainable side of the ceremony a
looking at the oils looking at how he
can involve young people looking at how
he can make the ceremony diverse and
relevant looking at how it can be
multi-faith it's a Christian ceremony
entrenched in Christianity but he's
brought in elements where Hindus seek
and Muslim faiths and Jewish faith can
be
part of the service I know that those
are details that are specific to him he
will absolutely have had a voice and a
say in those things
Christina and Alistair thank you both so
much Christina we're going to keep you
uh for a little bit longer but thank you
both very much thank you well as you
would expect security at the coronation
is of course going to be tight and
protests including from environmental
activists just stop oil are expected
over the weekend police have said any
disruption will be treated with a lower
tolerance level than normal our
correspondent Shaman Freeman Powell
reports
hundreds have already arrived and
thousands more are on the way it will be
one of the biggest ceremonial events
ever seen on The Streets of London and
the largest Security operation we've got
more than 300 VIPs Prime Ministers
presidents royalty from across the Globe
coming to our city will have hundreds of
thousands of people along the ceremonial
procession route and the job of the
police site is a really hard one to keep
us safe to keep us secure but to let
everyone to have a good time and I'm
really confident the preparation the
planning has been fantastic and
exemplary as you can see behind me some
of the hard-working police taken the
world is over break more than a million
people are expected to come to these
streets to celebrate the coronation and
most of them will be peaceful but with
crowds of this size just one incident
could have a huge impact
to ensure iron clad protection on the
king's big day more than 11 000 officers
have been deployed aided by new
legislation which carries up to a year
in jail for anyone tempted to cause
disruption our assessment of the Tipping
Point to say this protest has gone
beyond the reasonable inter being
disruptive and therefore we're going to
intervene it's a much lower tolerance
than it might be on a normal day that's
what this is about
but the lower tolerance approach seems
hard to Define I'm not going to go into
every individual case because it depends
on what's exactly on the ground that day
but it if that is going to fundamentally
obstruct the enjoyment and celebration
for a significant number of people
that's disrupting the events and that
would probably tip us into action
concerning for activists whose main
tactics involve civil disruption which
on Saturday could land them in jail what
is the right time in the right place you
know whenever they say this it's always
why don't you go to the pavement where
nobody can see you and do your little
protest but this is absolutely the right
time look at how many people are here in
Parliament this is the ideal opportunity
police have worked with activists to
provide a space where they can have
their say but the new laws mean they can
protest but not disrupt a controversial
measure the police have to get right as
it's being tested on the day the world
will be watching Shimon Freeman Powell
Sky News
well I will of course be two people
crowned tomorrow the coronation of the
queen consort will take place in a short
ceremony after the King has been
enthroned and has received the homage of
the congregation following the ceremony
she will be formally be known as Queen
Camilla she will receive a number of
items of regalia during the service
including the queen consorts rod and the
human rights Barrister and labor peer
Barona Helena Kennedy will carry that
rod and she joins me now and lovely to
see you so just explain what what you
actually have to do at what point do you
carry it and at what point in in the in
the centers the the The Queen's Rod is
um is a symbol in many ways of justice
so I feel it's quite appropriate for for
me because it's uh as a lawyer but uh
it's it's supposed to be about equity
and mercy and of course that role is in
the hands of the king but the idea is
that the queen concert supports him in
his fulfillment of those great virtues
and uh and the rod symbolizes that and
this particular Road was given it was
created for Mary of Medina in the 17th
century
1670s only when when she was crowned
along with James II and so it's a very
old artifact and I've been told to hand
that with great great care I have to be
quite nervous about dropping yes I'm
anxious about the fact that I had
mustn't trip as I go up some stairs into
the Abbey because it's it is it is
fragile and it has some it's uh it's
made of a number of pieces of ivory kept
is it normally kept in the tower all
these things are kept in the tower and
and so the the the they've been brought
for the for the ceremony to The Abbey by
those who are the keepers and they are
they handle them as if they were their
own precious children their babies you
know and so we're given very firm
instructions about looking after them so
you had the dress rehearsal yesterday
did you actually get to hold the the
idea Rod I did because it was very heavy
um it's actually it's not especially
heavy I'm too sort of carry it a bit
like this and um and and so the business
is about we were practicing piecing um
so that you get the timing right um as
we process into the into the Abbey and
so the The Queen's um regalia's brought
in actually first and uh it is
um there's a ring which is carried by
the by Lord chartres who was the bishop
of London and um and then uh I'm there
carrying this rod and um and a very
distinguished military man uh a general
as a Sir Patrick
um Sanders is carrying um another piece
of of the regalia and then behind comes
the crown
um which was Queen Mary is crying it's
been carried by the Duke of Wellington
so so this all happens you process into
the into the Abbey before uh the royal
couple do and then do you hand it over
to the queen herself no when when we
arrive we go up to the Altar and it's
handed in to be on the altar
um and it's handed to one of the uh
um uh one of the priests who is on the
old with the Archbishop of Canterbury so
it's handed over these different pieces
are handed over in preparation for the
arrival of the king and queen concert
and they take their seats and then the
the the whole it's the most incredible
ceremony I mean it's an amazing ritual
you must be incredibly proud to be part
of it well of course I I mean there's
there's something about the way in which
Britain is particularly good at this I
think that that I don't know that
anywhere else apart from possibly the
Vatican when the when there's absolute
people uh uh you know one of those
events like the people funeral I mean I
think Britain because of its long
history and and because of that sort of
sense of continuity that it brings
there's there's something about these
rituals and this one I mean does date
back thousands of years
um it will be very familiar to people
I'm I'm brought up as a Catholic and I
I'm a Catholic so that it feels very
Catholic to me and of course that's
partly as the bishop who's sitting with
me at the at the ceremony uh Lord
Charter says well that's because you
know that's how it was back in those
days when it was first created
um to uh to to anoint a king and uh and
you had a sense that that's what
um I think that's what makes it the
significance when you think of the queen
and how seriously she took the
responsibility and duties of of her
monarchy I think that's because this
ceremonial really lays a stress on what
is expected of someone that you are
noble and righteous and that you
preserve the values of of the nation and
the responsibility of that and it's you
feel the force of it when you're in The
Abbey at this um ceremony it's going to
be an absolutely fascinating day thank
you so much for joining us and telling
us what it's gonna be like we'll be
watching out for you fingers crossed you
won't trip I'm sure you'll be brilliant
thank you very much well let's take a
look at tomorrow's coronation procession
and the service in detail you heard from
him earlier in the program Sky's Royal
events commentator Aleister Bruce has
more
the king and queen consort depart
Buckingham Palace at 10 20 in The
Diamond Jubilee State coach drawn by six
Windsor Grays and process up the mull
escorted by four divisions of the
household cavalry
at walking pace the king's procession
passes under admiralty Arch and south of
Trafalgar Square into Whitehall
it passes several government buildings
Downing Street and the cenotoff before
entering Parliament Square
the king of quincots will pass by the
Palace of Westminster framed by the
flags of the commonwealth countries of
which he is now head
at the end of the 1.3 mile route the
Diamond Jubilee State coach pulls onto
broad Sanctuary outside the west gate of
Westminster Abbey ready for the
coronation service to begin at 11
o'clock
the king and queen consort will enter
through the Great West door at the rear
of the procession up the Nave of the
Abbey to what is known as the coronation
theater with the king and queen
consort's throne chairs in the center
between those and the high altar sets
the coronation chair
to the side are the chairs of a state
where they take their seats
these are the different stages of the
coronation the first is what is known as
the recognition the Archbishop of
Canterbury leads the presentation of the
king to the congregation at the Four
Points of the compass who respond by
acclaiming God saved the king second
comes the oath there will be two
returning to his chair of estate the
king promises to uphold Law And Justice
the Church of England and to look after
his people
he then signs both documents confirming
this commitment
the third stage is the anointing the
king's robes are removed and he sits in
the coronation chair where he is
Anointed with holy oil by the Archbishop
of Canterbury this will happen behind a
specially created anointing screen next
the investiture
remaining in the coronation chair the
Archbishop of Canterbury presents the
regalia and crans the king with Saint
Edward's crime
the next is the enthronement
the king is escorted to his throne chair
which symbolizes him taking possession
of the Kingdom
finally comes the homage
the Archbishop of Canterbury and the
prince of Wales do homage
and then the public will be invited to
do so if they wish
the queen consort is then anointed in
her chair of estate and is then crowned
before being escorted to the throne
Chair by the king's side
they then both receive Holy Communion
the king and queen then passed through
the screen to the shrine of Saint Edward
the Confessor
here the king is divested of his cloth
of gold vestments and Saint Edward's
Crown before putting on the purple robe
of a state and the Imperial State Crime
crowned and Anointed The King leaves the
Abbey down the Nave to the Great West
door
the return journey to Buckingham Palace
takes the same route in Reverse but this
time with the king and queen traveling
in the gold State coach
the coronation procession will be much
larger comprising the king and queen
members of the royal family and a much
larger Armed Forces contingent
after their arrival at the palace the
public will be allowed onto the mall for
a balcony appearance by the royal family
later that afternoon
well our correspondent Ryan and Mills is
at Westminster Abbey for us and Rhiannon
The Abbey behind you have seen so many
ceremonies that are of enormous
significance ceremonies of Sorrow
ceremonies of Joy but perhaps none as
significant as a coronation
well yeah as you say this is going to be
the main stage for what will be the most
symbolic part of the weekend where we'll
see that incredible pageantry an ancient
ritual play out it can feel more
different at the moment the road has
been closed behind us so that's a sense
of the anticipation that's building but
already there are still tourists taking
their photos spending that time Milling
around looking at the Abbey the doors of
course have closed at the moment but you
can see outside two topiary yew trees
which give us a sense of that very
natural feel that the king and queen
consort wanted to shape with the flowers
that are going to be used with the
service but tomorrow of course outside
of here it's going to be a sea of
military personnel as they accompany the
king and queen consort here to
Westminster Abbey and then all the way
back to Buckingham Palace of course
tomorrow it's going to be a service that
many of us have never witnessed In Our
Lifetime and those who do remember the
coronation some 70 years ago well for
them it's childhood memories including
for the man who is going to be at the
center of that service tomorrow and when
you speak to those who in the past have
worked with King Charles they say that
we shouldn't underestimate just how
emotional that moment is going to be of
course Westminster Abbey the place where
the Queen's funeral took place but also
where the king witnessed his own mother
her crowning moments back in 1953. ever
since we found out that this was the
weekend that this coronation was going
to be held messaging from the palace was
how this was going to be yes a very
traditional service but one that was
much more reflective of the United
Kingdom today and they've been drip
feeding little details about what we're
going to see in that service so for
example Faith leaders from different
faiths involved also British Empire
medal recipients making up the
congregation this was always going to
feel like a very different service of
course the queen in 1953 in her 20s we
now have a king who's in his 70s today
he tomorrow he is going to be
reconfirming that service to the United
Kingdom but of course in very different
times and he knows that there are
challenging years ahead for the monarchy
Rhiannon thanks so much
well will you be watching two out of
three people say that they will be
celebrating the coronation tomorrow that
is quite a lot of Bunting and warm beer
and as the final preparations begin our
correspondent Ashner talks to the people
putting together the finishing touches
it is a welcome coincidence that some of
those who live down this road remember
the last time it happened
Cynthia is expecting a more toned down
celebration to the one she watched aged
23. nonetheless she'll be tuning in from
the crack of dawn oh it was lovely you
know the queen was so pretty she was a
nice age you know they'll be so very
different there was more Pomp and
ceremony in the 1953 one don't you think
so you're probably right Ken says it
will be nostalgic but not in all the
ways he'd like I suppose you know if I
was a lot not younger I might say
another I would I would like to bring
down the mouth to watch from all people
coming together we'll get to see Ken two
British monarchs being crowned in your
lifetime what's that like
astronomical I think or or sign that I'm
getting old
they have a semblance of what to expect
the children of lawn Primary School in
Derby are full of expectation and
anticipation it's like symbolizing a new
era for the country and it's everyone's
um just coming together as a country to
watch it I can spend time with my family
and watch the king get crowned for the
country to celebrate Tim basically
getting crowned so that's what I'm
really looking forward to
at least they've got the necessary
attire and plenty of enthusiasm
these seamstresses have been helping the
nation get ready their machines haven't
stopped churning out the decorations in
the last two months we have produced 100
kilometers of bunting which is probably
about two or three times the amount of
bunting we would do in any one year and
that's just purely for the coronation
the coronation of one man big smile all
eyes may be on the capital but much of
the nation too will also be bathed in
Red White and Blue ashenaharanag Sky
News in Cambridgeshire
and if you want to post a message for
the new king and queen ahead of the
coronation you can do so on our website
just scan the QR code on your screen now
and it'll take you to our app and let's
take a quick look at some of the
messages that have been sent in so far
six-year-old Harry Penton wrote I'm very
excited for your coronation we have been
learning all about kings and queens in
school and tomorrow I'm having a tea
party at home with my mummy Daddy and
sister whilst we watch you get your
crown on the TV have a lovely day
John Barr says got my bunting up cannot
wait for tomorrow's celebrations I wish
you and queen Camilla all the very best
for the future you are my king
and Alex math said congratulations your
majesty you hold an enormous
responsibility on your shoulders I wish
you and your family all the very best
well let's talk now about Charles the
man what is the king like as a person
and how are this personality inform his
Reign well I'm joined Now by Sir Peter
westbrookot a former British ambassador
to the United States and it was also
former deputy private secretary to
Prince Charles uh sofita welcome and
also Christina kiriaku who is still with
us Charles worked she worked as Charles
as communication secretary uh while he
was Prince and she is still here with us
uh so Peter to see you first of all what
do you think will set the the Caroline
age apart from that of of Elizabeth II
well he's had a very long time to
prepare for the job and it's pretty
clear to me that from the outset he's
chosen to be his own Monarch obviously
masses of respect and affection for his
mother but we're seeing a king who is a
little more directly engaged a little
less sheltered behind a glass screen
from Ordinary People and so on not the
queen wasn't tremendously engaging when
you would talk to her in private but I
think the way in which for example the
king and his son and daughter-in-law
were out this afternoon reading the
crowds here it's not quite the sort of
thing that the queen used to do for
perfectly good reasons and of course the
queen she was 27 when she became a queen
and she had to she had to Pace herself
it was a long Reign the king is taking
over the age of 74. so obviously it's
going to be for a little less time but
he's also himself he's very much engaged
with people he's interested in people
it's not just that he's clever at
finding something to say to everyone
though he is but he's genuinely
interested and so there's a lot of
conversation there's a lot of activity
and of course he will be guided by the
British government on anything to do
with politics and and the role of the
monarchy because that's what the Monarch
has to do but he will remain interested
in and engaged and supportive on issues
like climate change and and uh young
offenders and and volunteering and many
other issues which he's been engaged
with and I think he will also be more
directly engaged as part of if you like
horrible phrase but I'm going to use it
anyway the soft power of Britain by
building up relationships with foreign
heads of state many of whom he knows
many of whom he likes in a way that I
think he probably feels is necessary
after the last six years of brexit where
the United Kingdom has been a little bit
turning in on itself
and Christina talking about his
personality there and I I don't want to
uh Peter but you know I was thinking
about the day after the queen died and
how he came here and I was here at
Buckingham Palace when he came and he
spoke to the crowds and perhaps nobody
really expected that of him and as you
say that that's been mirrored today
isn't it in in the walkabouts well it's
quite uh interesting because I was
reminded of um an occasion where I did
an engagement with her majesty the queen
and uh the then Prince of Wales Prince
Charles and she turned to me and she
said make sure he's quickly following
behind me he does talk so much he does
talk so much and then I'm waiting at the
other end with nothing to do and um that
is our King he loves meeting the public
I think I can recall in eight years him
canceling a public engagement once
because he had the most horrendous chest
infection and he virtually had to be
tied down to cancel that engagement he
was not going to cancel it this is a man
who has engage with the public I think
over the past 20 years he's done
something unbelievable like 20 000
public engagements he's the hardest
working member of the royal family next
to his sister Princess Anne and he
absolutely loves hearing from people
around the world around the Commonwealth
around Britain seeing what the
challenges are seeing what the issues
are and seeing how he might help his
patronages of 800 different charities
and you know when when he was Prince
Charles have just given him the most
enormous insight into what the
difficulties and the needs are
and and taking on from that so Peter we
talked about the the things that he
would do differently to the queen but
you know he has had this extraordinary
active life throughout his entire life
in waiting almost had an opportunity to
engage with thousands and thousands of
Charities
um but but what kind of preparations do
you think that the queen
helped him with perhaps that you know
perhaps I don't know if he realized that
she was subconsciously kind of laying
the ground with him I would say speaking
entirely personally of course that there
were two particular things she did for
him before she died one was to make very
plain that she wished Camilla to be
known as Supreme consort so that ended
the debate if ever there was still a
debate and I I know that that made an
enormous difference to His Majesty of
course it would you know but but that
wasn't important the other thing is that
many people forget that the the British
monarch is not automatically the head of
the Commonwealth and so why the other
thing that she did was to arrange for
the other heads of government in
Commonwealth to agree that her son uh
our new King Charles would be the head
of the Commonwealth and that was I think
extremely helpful it helps
the continuity of the relationship
between the United Kingdom and The
Commonwealth but particularly the
British royal family in the Commonwealth
and that's more than 50 different
countries which are part of a voluntary
Group which come together with shared
values and an appreciation of democracy
and human rights which is very important
and of course never forget that he's
also a head of state of 15 different
countries which we call Realms some of
them tiny in the Caribbean some of them
enormous Australia and Canada New
Zealand and so on so that bit of if you
like laying the ground for the king to
remain as she was you know the head of
state of those countries and the head of
the Commonwealth as well as organizing
uh helpfully his own private life I
think with the two to me most important
things that she did before she died for
her son when you're nodding as well so
Peter westpacot and Christina thank you
both so much
well you're watching Sky News coming up
how popular is King Charles we find out
what the public think about the Royal
Family
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to a Sky News special
program live from outside Buckingham
Palace on the eve of the coronation this
is of course the mile uh thousands and
thousands of people lining the road down
there preparing to camp out some for a
second night to get a decent view of the
pageantry tomorrow uh Sky correspondent
Alice Porter is in with the crowds I
don't know if she's got a crown herself
Alice it's a great atmosphere down there
isn't it and the sun is shining
it really is it's a gorgeous evening
here on the mountain people seem to be
having such a good time I think it's
definitely a few people with a few
glasses of wine in hand ready to pull
their night ahead as they camp out on
the mile including these two ladies here
hello how are you feeling about camping
out overnight ahead of the big day
tomorrow it's a bit of an adventure
we've never done it before
and the atmosphere is just electric I
think is the cheering cheerings behind
us really sort of say it all and we were
having a bit of a joke weren't we that
someone was coming through your sitting
room because we've got everyone's got
dens haven't they they've claimed their
sport we've got our little lounges
everyone has and why was it so important
to camp out to be here all day ahead of
tomorrow for the king to come past he's
our King
and he deserves it yes very simple
because both of you I know you said to
me you've both been to a number of very
important Royal events before how do you
think this will compare to some of the
other ones
I haven't witnessed anything like this
because I haven't camped out I've just
sort of done seeing the queen uh lying
in state and that's about it and that
was very somber
um it was a long night nine hours
this is really sort of this is more fun
yeah it's fun and it's Child's Play and
we sat down yes well I hope you are both
able to get some sleep tonight I think
it might be tricky for a few people
it'll be a bit noisy thank you very much
for speaking to us and I hope you have a
good day tomorrow because this is very
much where the action will be happening
at 20 past 10 tomorrow where King
Charles will leave Buckingham Palace and
make his way along the mile to
Westminster Abbey
Alice thanks so much
well the Archbishop of Canterbury is
going to play a really crucial role in
officiating the ceremony tomorrow the
most Reverend Justin Welby explained to
Sky News how much planning had gone into
tomorrow's event
my mood is first of all it's not
principally about me it's about the king
and it's a service it's a Christian
service it's about God
um but yes it's
um I'm very conscious of of what a huge
privilege it is to do it and we've been
doing lots of rehearsals since February
and you know it's slowly coming together
during the day I am spending a lot of
time obviously thinking through what
we're doing and how we're doing it and
working with others it's been
enormously collaborative we've been
working with the palace with the
government with
you know all kinds of different groups
and it's just been
really enjoyable with the Abbey
lots of laughter lots of fun and very
serious thoughtful work the king is
someone who it is very easy to work with
he is
really kind he pays great attention
he thinks very deeply about these things
you can see his Christian faith comes
through the whole time
and it's been really fun but it is also
a moment that says
we're going to draw on our tradition
we're going to reflect the country as it
is now and we're going to look forward
with hope and draw people together and
the the point of the coronation why do
we need a coronation we need a
coronation to celebrate all we have been
all we are and all we will be the they
know it or not and most of them would
say oh no no I just try and help out
um it's inclusive and
I think people will say oh there's so
many good things happening in this
country people when they see it they'll
realize why it reaches out I mean the
first thing that happens is a
one of the young
young people choristers there present
uh say to the king
you're welcome and the King's saying I
come not to be served but to serve and
that's the theme of the service serving
one another not just the king to the
nation but each of us to everyone
foreign years ago Charles's mother the
late Queen was crowned six Maids of
Honor flanked Queen Elizabeth in 1953
one of them lady Roseberry Mia spoke to
Sky News and reflected on the service
it was magical I mean it was
you know the music the color the
the whole sense of majesty was amazing
it was great it was so beautifully
choreographed I suppose you can't say
anything more than that it all went like
the Clockwork it was very
very easy in those days you know you you
drove up to the airport parked your car
got down since hello to the policeman
who was drinking a cup of tea in a
little box hello girls who said we just
walked in no Bits of Paper no
no
a different world
there was a box
with a queen mother and Princess
Margaret and
Prince Charles and
a few aunts and uncles I think all in
this box and you could hear Prince
Charles sort of running up and down and
the Queen Mother sort of getting hold of
him and telling him to sit down but I
mean it was only what was he thought and
of course when we got back to the
to Buckingham Palace and the queen took
off a crowd put it on the table and he
appeared and wrapped it and shot up the
passage
well it is now less than 24 hours to go
to the coronation and in a timely boost
for the royal family King Charles is
becoming more popular in the run-up to
the big event according to an exclusive
Poll for Sky News but it also found that
support for a republic has risen to its
highest level since the 1990s a home
editor Jason Farrell reports
Kennelworth in Warwickshire a fortress
for King John lancastrians Tudors
Elizabeth the first here you'll find a
giant ruler of royal succession and the
strength of this timeline through our
history has always depended on events
and who wears the crown these walls may
have crumbled but King Charles inherits
a country still predominantly monarchist
however Sky News ipsos poll shows
support for a republic is at 25 percent
its highest since the early 90s so what
makes a popular monarch well I think
it's a number of factors of course but
firstly I'd say a monarch shouldn't
really kill or persecute its subjects
that's obviously a clear thing but also
it's all about Society whether Society
did well at the time was it prosperous
was it politically stable were there
Wars I mean Elizabeth the first for
example has gone down as being called
Gloriana and good Queen Beth and I think
that's because she had such a stable
long reign
and in these times of financial
difficulty our polls shows that more
than half of us feel the Royals get too
much public money I uh respected the
kings of you know
in the past where they'll be out in the
battlefields yeah but
you don't care about it it's a privilege
it's a very privileged accident of birth
thing or the costs of Fortune to see
what see the lavishness of it and the
expense of it one day I think they
represent the UK all over the world but
they do visits bring everyone together
the Commonwealth are they good value for
money I think I think so especially a
slim down monarchy you know sort of
working Royals focus on that it's
survived a thousand years but whether
people think the monarchy will exist in
another 50 years time fluctuates
depending on events 69 said yes in 1990
dropping dramatically to 36 percent in
1992 during the Queen's Anna cerebrales
the breakdown of three of her children's
marriages and revelation of Charles's
affair with Camilla then after the death
of Diana in 1997 came the Crown's
biggest crisis belief in the monarchy's
durability dipped below 30 percent it's
all-time low over the next 15 years the
queen revived people's faith in the
institution and in the year of the
Diamond Jubilee and the Olympics where
the queen was part of the ceremony 60 of
people thought the monarchy would endure
another half century but that has dipped
again amid recent scandals of prince
Andrew and Harry and Megan cutting
themselves loose from the Royal fold
Skye's poll shows the figure is now at
46 percent
and the Scottish are least supportive of
the monarchy according to our poll this
was the cue for the book of
congratulations in Glasgow and here we
found little enthusiasm for the big day
especially with the number of people
striking who should be getting a wage
increase
um it's totally well it's never the
right time for them to be doing it but
it's it couldn't be worse it's got
people saying oh tourism people come
watch it but when you've got the rest of
the nation like literally struggling day
to day I think it's absolutely
disgusting personally I know in Scotland
there's probably not the same banners
and Street parties but as a family we're
going to celebrate it just at home
quietly watch it on Italian stuff and
have the family around interestingly
over more recent years Charles has seen
his personal favorability rise from 32
in March 2018 to 52 today whereas his
youngest son Prince Harry who was hugely
popular just five years ago with a 65
rating is now third most unpopular of
the key Royals just ahead of his wife
Megan and prince Andrew William is the
most popular Royal
and William is key to Royal longevity
especially among the 18 to 35 year olds
who are 10 more likely to be Republicans
reflected in the views of these
30-somethings drinking in the Royal pug
in Royal Limington Spa are you
interested in the Monica no not really
it sounds bad but no I'm not I love the
monarchy however I do feel that King
Charles should have stepped aside and
met will and Kate in they don't really I
don't seem to do anything for us I don't
know what I don't know what it is they
do to be honest apart from bringing
money into London there are lessons in
recent and ancient history for now
Britain wants to maintain its monarchy
just a cheaper version Jason Farrell Sky
News
well Christina kiriako former
communication secretary to then Prince
Charles and Duchess of Cornwall is here
with us and Christina what do you make
of of the coronation effect Charles now
more popular than the royal family as a
whole do you think he's going to be a
popular King
I hope he's going to be a very popular
King because he's put the work in and
he's taken the ridicule when he first
mentioned plastic pollution in the 70s
he was ridiculed when he mentioned
organic farming he was ridiculed when he
mentioned sustainability and climate
change he was ridiculed everyone's
always thought he was mad but his future
gazing has stood the test of time I
think it's easy with anyone but
particularly someone who's under the
most intense public scrutiny as the King
has been to remember the moments when
mistakes have been made but when you
think 70 years in public service those
mistakes are few you talk about the 70
years we've got some footage now of the
coronation back in 1953.
um and just looking at these images it
really reminds you how much times have
changed and we talk a lot about all the
things the queen saw during her Reign
and the changes to society but of course
Charles was there and saw them all too
he was there and in the era when the
queen was crowned it's it's easy to
forget that television had only really
just come into being and there weren't
really any studio lights in the Abbey
there was one broadcaster broadcasting
from The Abbey this is a modern
celebration it's a celebration with
global media attending it's it's a
celebration of a king who accedes to the
throne with 70 years experience he has
an opinion and we know what he stands
for Christina thank you so much lovely
to speak to you well that's it for all
the Sky News special program
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]